c'est la ruée dans les magasins comme
chaque année tout le monde s'y prend au
dernier moment
l école c'est tout de même pour mardi
prochain les sens sont à la fête car eux
n'ont qu'à choisir et ils ont des idées
bien arrêtées croyable pour les parents
c'est un autre problème
après les dépenses des vacances le coût
de la rentrée est une saignée
supplémentaire dans le porte-monnaie
famille
[Musique]
on peut dire que la rentrée est
difficile pour les mères de famille
puisque les vêtements air d'augmenter
d'une manière considérable
certes si l'on prenait le même type de
produit que celui fabriqué l'année
dernière il serait difficile d'arriver à
une hausse de prix inférieur à 10% pour
des raisons de coûts de structure que ce
soit en charge salariale ou au niveau du
tissu enfin niveau des fournitures mais
il faut lire également qu'il ya eu une
certaine recherche de la part des
fabricants français pour offrir un
certain nombre de produits qui soient
des produits de qualité avec une
certaine durabilité et surtout une très
grande créativité
les stylistes pour enfants ont prévu un
hiver rigoureux avec de grosses écharpes
et bonnets du côté des trench coat pour
les garçons et des ponchos pour les
petites filles
[Musique]
les pulls sont multicolores et le
jacquard la vedette des chaussures
confortables des boots fourrées sur des
jeans dans mes bottes des pantalons
bouffants des droits le plus souvent en
velours côtelé
dans les chemises les manteaux les
écharpes la mode est aux tissus écossais
[Musique]
en classe un retour du sart au noir pour
les garçons fleury pour les petites
filles sages délurée les robes également
son romantique
[Musique]
beaucoup de combinaisons unisexe et des
salopettes élégante pour les petits gars
les blousons pour filles et garçons sont
en cuir avec des cols de fourrure que le
motif d'achat pour un enfant c'est
d'abord que l'esthétique y voit sur un
village on le voit sur une image qui a
envie et puis après il faut que ce soit
est-ce qu'on peut déceler déjà chez
l'enfant s'il a du goût ou pas je pense
que l'enfant quand il contenait
il a un certain goût il n'a pas de
mauvais goût en tout cas et prétend
qu'il a plus de boucles adultes donner
un garçon et une petite fille de 7 ou 8
ans deux pommes une pomme qui tourne
bunton
mais un peu marre
le ca du canada et puis donner une pomme
bien brillantes il va choisir la bonne
brillant parce que c'est l'esthétique
qui choisit et en matière de vêtements
d'enfants c'est exactement la même chose
parce que l'enfant aux autres par
rapport à l'adulte oui alors l'enfant
c'est vrai la mode c'est un jeu parce
que la mode change a été fait maire il
faut qu'elle soit comme ça et
l'enfant il est bien dans sa peau et
dans un vêtement c'est toujours aussi
mon leitmotiv peut-être bien vraiment ça
pour l'enfant il a pas de problème
quelque chose qui lui plaît à le porter
y a pas de complexe absolument car on
perd les trois coups de la rentrée
peuvent être frappés
il y aura tout de même sans doute
quelques scènes déchirantes à la porte
des maternelles
[Musique]